an unusual move the top military brass
walking a fine line but appearing to
publicly question their boss the u.s
president's version of events in
afghanistan
president joe biden had said he couldn't
recall any military adviser recommending
he keep troops in afghanistan before he
ordered the withdrawal the top military
bosses appeared to contradict that i
won't share my personal recommendation
to the president but i will give you my
honest opinion and my honest opinion and
view shaped my recommendation i
recommended that we maintain 2500 troops
in afghanistan
the white house responded i would note
today in the testimony that was given by
secretary austin by general milley they
made clear secretary austin specifically
said if you stayed there at a
forced posture of 2500 certainly you'd
be in a fight with the taliban and you'd
have to reinforce
from the senators dueling narratives
over which president is to blame for the
chaos donald trump who made a deal with
the taliban to take troops out or
president biden who set the date for
removal anyone who says the last few
months were a failure but everything
before that was great
clearly hasn't been paying attention
because of the date certain rather than
a conditions based withdrawal
because of a decision that was made by
our president
because of that we left american
citizens behind
so what went wrong this hearing didn't
produce any real answers but the
military admitted here something did we
helped build the state mr chairman but
we could not forge a nation
the fact that the afghan army that we
and our partners trained simply melted
away
in many cases without firing a shot took
us all by surprise and it would be
dishonest to claim otherwise the
pentagon is conducting its own review of
its actions but some senators say that's
not enough they're calling for the
creation of an independent commission
that can look at what went wrong not
just at the end but during the entirety
of america's longest war
patti culhane al jazeera washington
mark kimmed served as assistant
secretary of state for political
military affairs he says it will be
crucial to understand how president
biden missed the general's
recommendations
the generals made the recommendations
probably in a national security council
meeting the president may or may not
have been there
but in any case his own staff
had the responsibility to brief
president biden on the conduct of those
meetings and those recommendations that
came from his military and secretary
defense
so either president biden was not
informed for which
some of his people ought to be held
responsible or he was informed but
misunderstood what the commanders on the
ground and the u.s military were saying
i think we've got to stand back and
realize that we fought inside of
afghanistan for 20 years
we went in to fight al-qaeda we defeated
al-qaeda we
brought bin laden to justice but with
this collapse that we're seeing in
afghanistan right now candidly all of
the successes and all of the effort that
we put into afghanistan has now been
reversed
the worst possible outcome would be that
the taliban allow al qaeda isis k and
other terrorist groups
to come back into afghanistan and take
advantage of ungoverned spaces within
afghanistan to set up training camps
and plot future attacks in both europe
and the united states
so that's the greatest danger we have
and our ability to control that i think
general milley was saying is somewhat
limited